[Musik]
highlight unbestritten am heutigen
mittwoch ist die ankunft frecce
tricolore der italienischen staffel die
er doch weltberühmt sind und da stellt
sich natürlich die frage ob die ein
etwas anderes betreuungs handling
brauchen als alle anderen das weiß
natürlich ein normaler best nämlich ihre
betreuer jörg die frecce tricolori
brauchen gegen eine besondere behandlung
eine besondere behandlung oder ist das
wohl bei einer anderen auch nein von
erfahrungen heraus sind das recht ist
das ein recht unkomplizierte steam und
wir werden das zu zweit organisieren und
mit mit dieser crew mit ihm gemeinsam
lösen und jetzt jährlich aus der
erfahrung heraus wieder einen schönen
verlauf machen
ihrer erfahrung nach sind die frecce
tricolori besonders zu behandeln oder
ist es wie bei jedem anderen auch sind
grundsätzlich gleich zu behandeln das
einzige was eventuell ist diese
pressetermine aufgrund ihres
bekanntheitsgrades die pressetermine
fototermine müssen organisiert und
abgesprochen werden ansonsten ist die
behandlung von der grün von ihm
gleich jeder nation fabrikate ziehen sie
also gelandet wie froh sind sie dass sie
auch heuer wieder mit dabei sind sie ja
schon
die freude ist riesengroß die frecce
tricolore ist einer unserer größten
highlights der show und sie sind auch
schon unsere stammgäste
was für ein gefühl haben sind für ihre
performance in zeltweg 2009 petaquilla
gehen
wir sind sehr froh hier zu sein das
letzte mal waren wir vor zwei jahren
hier die performance hier ist immer sehr
speziell das flugfeld von bergen umgeben
ist angerer friedhof ein toller junge
das ist ein ganz speziellen szenarien
[Musik]
neben den frecce tricolori gibt es bei
den flying es noch zahlreiche andere
spektakuläre fahrzeuge zu bestatten
[Musik]
wir stehen hier vor der pleite und ein
amerikanisches überwachungsflugzeug das
in sizilien in italien stationiert ist
und heute zum ersten mal in zeltweg zu
sehen ist die besondere attraktion die
vielen überwachung sind so an die schon
von außen erkennbar sind da gibt es
wirklich viel zu sehen einige teilnehmer
nutzen den tag auch für ein ausgiebiges
drin wie zb die bartoli agiler
auch wenn es vermutlich an den beiden
veranstaltungstagen aufgrund meiner in
der sonne keine sonnenbrände geben wird
und mögliche unwetter die erbauer
2009/10 beeinträchtigen können das steht
noch nicht fest
die jetzige vorher sorge ist ja nicht so
schlecht
also es wird keine katastrophen wetter
wir werden wahrscheinlich wolken
erwarten können aber damit bekommt
keinen sonnenstich ich bin optimistisch
dass man ein schönes programm zustande
bringen